hemos estado haciendo varias cosas
interesantes en los últimos vídeos y ya
dejamos atrás las hipótesis del mundo
newtoniana verdad en donde el paso del
tiempo es el mismo en todo marco de
referencia inercial es decir que el
tiempo sea absoluto verdad también
dejamos atrás la idea de que el espacio
sea absoluto es decir que un metro en
una cierta dirección en mi marco de
referencia sea un metro en por ejemplo
en tu marco de referencia y esto nos
ayuda a reconciliarnos con las
observaciones que tenemos del universo
verdad y estas observaciones nos llevan
a la idea de que la velocidad de la luz
sea absoluta y que siempre será
aproximadamente 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
sobre segundo y cuando dejamos las
hipótesis del espacio y el tiempo
absolutos pero suponiendo que la
velocidad de la luz es absoluta entonces
obtuvimos un diagrama bastante bastante
interesante verdad ya que obtuvimos que
el eje
x prima forma un ángulo respecto al eje
x verdad y una pregunta que podríamos
hacer es cuánto mide ese ángulo y
digamos por la forma en que lo dibujé
pareciera que este ángulo verdad que
forma el eje x prima con el eje x parece
ser el mismo ángulo que forma el eje 7
prima con el an con el con el eje se ve
muy bien así que lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es convencernos de que en
efecto dichos ángulos miden lo mismo muy
bien y recordemos que hace un par de
vídeos desarrollamos el experimento
mental en donde nuestra amiga verdad
pasaba sobre una sobre nosotros en una
nave espacial verdad pero en el segundo
-1 ella disparaba un fotón de luz hacia
la siguiente nave que se encontraba a
tres por diez a los ocho metros de
distancia y dicha nave tenía un espejo
que hacía que dicho fotón
hacia la nave de nuestra amiga verdad y
allí supusimos que digamos que la marca
para poner 3 por 10 a la 8 metros en
este eje y la marca para medir un
segundo en el eje vertical en realidad
median lo mismo ahora esto tiene más
sentido pues ya llamamos a este punto ya
no le pusimos un segundo sino 3 por 10 a
la 8 metros así que cuando vemos la
trayectoria del fotón en los diagramas
siempre es una recta formando un ángulo
de 45 grados verdad ya sea en la
dirección positiva o en la dirección
negativa verdad entonces todo esto lo
hemos usado para ver dónde quedaba el
eje x prima digamos ahora sobre puestos
sobre mi marco de referencia verdad
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es ver qué
ocurre con este ángulo de aquí vamos a
ver qué ocurre con este ángulo de aquí
que voy a llamar
muy bien y para poder verificar que en
efecto es este mismo ángulo que forma el
eje xy el eje x prima
vamos a extender vamos a extender esta
recta hacerlo un poquito mejor
vamos a extender esta recta hasta tocar
con el eje tanto en esa dirección como
esta otra dirección
muy bien entonces en ambas direcciones
lo extendemos verdad y podemos ver que
es justamente como lo como lo
construimos pues estos ángulos son de 45
grados verdad este ángulo es de 45
grados este ángulo también será de 45
grados
entonces fijémonos ahora en este
triángulo que tenemos en medio que de
hecho voy a marcar con algún color
digamos con este color más o menos rosa
vamos a hacerlo un poquito menos
brillante muy bien este color rosa muy
bien fijémonos en este triángulo
entonces lo que podemos observar de este
triángulo es que es un triángulo
isósceles verdad porque si nos fijamos
por ejemplo en esta marca aquí en esta
marca tenemos 3 x 10 a la 8 metros
verdad mientras que en esta otra marca
también tendremos 3 x 10 a la 8 metros
entonces este lado es igual a éste
otro lado y lo que nosotros sabemos de
los triángulos isósceles es que los
ángulos que se encuentran en la base son
congruentes verdad estos ángulos miden
lo mismo es decir son congruentes ahora
lo que podemos concluir de esto es que
entonces los este ángulo que se
encuentra digamos afuera y este otro
ángulo que se encuentra afuera también
son congruentes verdad simplemente
porque son los ángulos suplementarios de
estos dos que tenemos dentro es decir la
suma de ellos dos debe ser 180 grados
verdad pero si estos miden lo mismo pues
entonces estos azules deben medir
también lo mismo verdad entonces ahora
lo que podemos observar es que pasa con
este triángulo que estoy marcando con
verde
triángulo que estoy marcando con verde y
este otro triángulo que estoy marcando
con verde fijémonos muy bien aquí tengo
un ángulo de 45 grados acá también tengo
un ángulo de 45 grados aquí tengo un
ángulo que es igual a este otro azul
verdad coinciden en esos dos ángulos y
aquí tengo el ángulo alfa bueno pues
como estos dos triángulos coinciden en
dos ángulos el tercero también tiene que
ser el mismo entonces no sé vamos a
ponerlo con cuatro líneas verdad ya
hemos usado
2 y 3 este ángulo también tiene que ser
alfa verdad si eso eso es consecuencia
de que la suma de los ángulos internos
de un triángulo suma 180 grados siempre
verdad y esto resulta muy pero muy
interesante verdad este dibujo posee
como como una belleza que se deriva de
la simetría verdad y viene del hecho de
que la velocidad de la luz siempre es
aproximadamente 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
sobre segundos en cualquier marco de
referencia inercial así que si
regresamos a mi marco de referencia y
vemos la trayectoria de mi fotón que yo
emitía el tiempo te igual a 0 verdad
entonces su trayectoria en este diagrama
se verá más o menos
así verdad tiene que ser una línea de 45
grados pero qué parte del origen verdad
entonces ahí tenemos esta línea verdad
entonces esa sería la trayectoria de mi
fotón se vería así en el espacio-tiempo
de minkowski verdad entonces notemos
desde el punto de vista de mi amiga
verdad tomemos digamos algún punto por
aquí y ahorita ahorita lo pongo tomemos
un punto por aquí digamos este punto por
aquí vamos a ver cuáles son digamos las
coordenadas de ese punto verdad entonces
trazamos algo así verdad para poder
determinar su coordenada
el eje se te prima y trazamos otra por
acá para ver en el eje x prima verdad
entonces lo que podemos ver es que
coinciden y esto tiene sentido verdad en
un metro luz avanza un metro entonces
aún está viajando a la velocidad de la
luz verdad desde el punto de vista de mi
amiga aunque aunque en realidad ella se
está moviendo a la mitad de la velocidad
de la luz respecto de mi verdad y puedes
pensar que ocurriría así si mi amiga se
moviera más rápido verdad
pongamos digamos esa situación
hipotética digamos vamos a poner el eje
7 prima aquí estaría el eje
de mi prima vamos a ponerle mejor mi
prima porque es otra situación y aquí
estará el eje x mi prima verdad aquí
estará el eje x mi prima aquí ya casi no
se ve este es el eje x mi prima muy bien
entonces a medida que ese marco de
referencia de mi amiga se acerca a la
velocidad de la luz desde mi marco de
referencia sus ejes se van a pachu rando
verdad estos ejes se van a pachu rando
hacia esta línea de 45 grados que pasa
por el origen verdad ahora bien otra
cosa que quiero que meditemos sobre todo
en el próximo vídeo porque aquí ya hemos
hablado de muchas otras muchos muchos
conceptos verdad entonces lo que quiero
que meditemos es que hay siempre una
asimetría en estos diagrama es verdad si
mi amiga se mueve a la mitad de la
velocidad de la luz en la dirección
positiva con respecto
respecto a mi marco de referencia
yo me moveré a la mitad de la velocidad
de la luz en la dirección negativa sobre
el eje x prima verdad en el marco en el
marco de referencia de mi amiga así que
ve pensando cómo se vería mi marco de
referencia si lo ponemos sobre el suyo